so Teresa may in a bid to embrace our
freedom from the EU has hatched a plan
for a festival of all things British a
farewell fingers up to the barmy
brussels bureaucrats and who wouldn't
want to walk away in style with our
heads held high
but it's no need to reinvent the field
from 1880 and annually up until 1999 we
as a nation held a royal tournament a
celebration of the men and women who
really make this country great
our frontman sauce is displaying why
they are revered as the best in the
world why we as a small island lead the
way in defending ourselves televised to
the nation and the rest of the world
attended by the fake been herself this
extravaganza eclipsed anything the
Europeans could muster by a statutory
mile flags waving drums beating and
gunners gunning I say bring back the
Royal tournament it's an event of
national importance and Theresa if you
really want to showcase our nation leave
it up to me I'll sort it out for you
while you concentrate on cutting this
away for the benefit of viewers that
might not be so familiar with the Royal
time it just give us a quick heads-up
about what it was how it worked okay so
the royal tournament the last one I did
in fact it's it's a military tactic it's
like a military tattoo it showcases
things like the field Gunners the rule
Marines always used to be there
abseiling what sort of stuff but it
serves as more than that it's like a
celebration of what our forces have
achieved and what our country is at what
we've achieved as a nation okay so I
feel a few different things about this
first of all I'm quite uncomfortable
when I see country is displaying their
military might in organised processions
and yeah it makes me feel it makes me
feel like it's Willy waving and I know
that's probably not you it makes me feel
I don't want to be naked yeah okay right
yeah oh that's an I'm never gonna unsee
that image you know that don't you
my point is when countries display their
military might I see it in some ways I
understand the celebratory aspect but I
also see it's quite an ticket and a
stiff upper lip and we've got a lot more
dignity and humility in the way that we
do things we don't like march around
that the North Koreans and get out the
biggest guns we've got in the but we do
showcase it in a way that promotes us do
not mean and it's a great thing for not
only for equipment but also for
retention you worry them final points
that you've just said it's a great
opportunity to show what we've achieved
there's many people that are quite angry
about foreign policy sometimes quite
angry about where British military have
been deployed and the things that
they've been told to do whilst they're
there and I worry about so you know
she's just still accept that the
environment that the military over the
years has created for us to live thanks
for you so in summary before everyone
else comes in I agree with you that we
do need something that's a mechanism to
bring us together and to feel proud of
our nation but I'm just not sure if
doing an exclusively military version of
that is where I am this is why I said
frontline services because I do believe
we should be celebrating our ambulance
service our police forces our nurses so
the kupets and that's why I said rehash
it slightly do not man so I understand
where you're coming from and understand
where the military might have upsetting
people who are poor do I still prepared
to take the take the environment they
live in but quick quote so only 15% of
18 to 24 year olds describe themselves
as very patriotic so in terms of the
next generation I don't think you
particularly have an audience for this
and I think we should be sound of the
military academy in the world and I'll
start there beyond a 15 year old girl
when we stood up to sing the national
words I'm absolutely appalled and so you
know that sort of thing is the sort of
thing we need to be working in the
schools giving people direction and
going on to to Ephrata conversations
throughout the day we have more
direction
more aim and more point in life you know
my issue with this is the cost so a
couple of weeks last week you were
talking about which I completely agreed
with you about how we get more
ex-servicemen into work so I'd rather we
spent the money on programs like that
then military pageantry the military
this gives people to stand on a pedestal
and they can explain what they've been
doing and how they are so in terms of
resettlement business and see that these
soldiers there's a definite disconnect
between the Armed Forces and the public
and that's correct
all I'm saying is that more needs to be
done for the public to understand the
military there's a misunderstanding of
what the role of the military that's why
we turn that move Armed Forces Day
Imperial Armed Forces Day as a sensor
I'm suspicious of the notion a bit like
Michelle actually with a Willie waving
comment I'm suspicious of the notion are
the best way to reconnect the
disconnected public perhaps for example
to address what is needed could be some
form of organized through schools to go
and visit you can address this thing
last time I saw it was in the think like
an away day say for example they came to
my school and I'm 15 they took me and
everyone at one boys and girls and we
went to learn how to with the reinstated
for that I said for recruitment so that
young people can go and see what's going
on for the retention of the guys because
it gives them a look window to get the
show off every year I mean and for the
route and for the resettlement of guys
so that they can go right I am now a
veteran and the royal tournament is
raising issues of showing people and I
can go and meet people there we waste
money everywhere I have some sympathy
with you today because last week we were
talking about what I found a shocking
statistic which is the fact that it's
very difficult for ex servicemen and
women to find jobs yeah and I would have
thought employers would love them
because they've shown you know
commitment and I think we talked about
this and I agree I think there is a
cultural problem in this country that we
don't have a good relationship we should
all appreciate what they do for us but
we couldn't enjoy all of the benefits we
enjoy being this country we didn't have
a military that we're keeping us safe so
I definitely agree there is a disconnect
like you were saying as well Majid and I
think you're right that we should think
about ways to breathe like bridge that
cultural to buy a beauty pageant bar I I
do agree with some the others are strike
me I'm sure you know about this gene in
Garner lots of African countries have
Independence Day yeah where everyone
parades schoolchildren nurses teachers
doctors the military to politicians
everyone arraigned yeah and it's the
celebration of the nation and they can
do that because they've got quite a
cohesive identity as a nation that's
only 60 years old only been independent
for you know for a few decades and they
built this idea of a nation and people
really buy into it and we don't have
that and that is the problem we have is
that the reasons we don't have a case of
sense of Britishness are very deep and I
don't think a parade is going to solve
them and I think there's some knowledge
I do think we're in danger of letting
Tereza may get off the hook here and
focusing just on Phil here's what
Theresa May said about the actual
festival she wants to organize almost 70
years ago the festival Britain stood as
a symbol of change Britain once again
stands on the cusp of a new future as an
outward facing global trading nation we
want to showcase what makes our country
great
pause for dramatic effect today we want
to capture that spirit for a new
generation celebrate our nation's
diversity and talent and mark this
moment of national renewal with a
once-in-a-generation celebration she's
talking about a festival she wants to
organize to boost herself and her
ratings I would love to see
ex-servicemen being trained up as
teachers talking about campaigns here's
a worthy one guys you have to move on
there's a worthy campaign for your
attention you may have noticed that
we've had some information on the bottom
of your screens throughout the program
about Sky News campaign make debates
happen which is calling for an
independent Commission to ensure TV
debates become a regular fixture of UK
elections we've had some great supports
over the past few days here some of the
highlights is an excellent idea I'll
support the petitioner as soon as I get
the opportunity to sign it I will it's
exactly what we need they are essential
I certainly support Sky's campaign we've
always wanted debates between leaders
not just the party leaders but also with
the spokespersons for different
departments the public do you expect it
and I think they're entitled to it it's
very much to the credit of Sky that
they've come up with this proposal and
they agree with Sky News and what's more
I think you should go further I think
you should have deputy leaders debates
as well and I'd love to be part of it I
think it's an excellent idea I think the
public has a right to hear from all
parties I do think that actually leaders
debates are are here to stay I think
they're great some wasps are looking
really healthy and don't forget you can
join in the campaign by signing the
petition at Sky News calm thought / make
debates happen and if you want to show
your support
use the hashtag make debates happen